talk to me about how you can tell
the
dating preferences of a society based on
the
ratio of their fingers
um it
sounds bizarre doesn't it but it seems
to work quite well and and this was
established um both in in animals and in
in humans it works quite well in
primates
but it seems that the genes that control
the length of the fingers and
particularly the second and the fourth
digits so your
index finger and your
uh ring finger are determined
uh by
uh or are influenced during development
by testosterone load
uh in in the womb so the fetal uh the
load that the fetus is of testosterone
from the mother that the fetus is
exposed to
um the higher that is
um
the
uh shorter
the index finger is
so more testosterone is shorter index
finger yes shorter index finger means
that um
you
are on the whole more
likely to be promiscuous and they and
it's kind of indicative of high
testosterone levels them both internally
to you so some
male babies because they're obviously
switching over
uh from being a kind of generic
um
non-sex so so female body form is the
default
yeah
i remember i don't i got to interject
there there is a um i think it's called
gone girl which was a movie kind of a
thriller movie a few years ago i'm
pretty sure that the line was in that
and the the female protagonist in it is
very manipulative and
she
uses this line that would have slipped
under the radar for a lot of people but
she points at the guy and she says the
male form is an aberration
and that's so cool right because it's
the reason that men have got nipples
right you need to be born with all of
the
elements all of the individual bits that
could make a woman and then
you you turn from a kind of nothingness
that could be a woman into a man and
then that was why she said she pointed
at him and she says the male form is an
aberration
yeah well this is also what's known
um as the race to be male because it
depends on how fast
the fetus grows so it's a combination
of having a y chromosome
and how how how much fat the baby lays
lays down and that switches the brain
over
from this kind of generic female brain
into a male brain which is clearly
missing lots of bits that should be
there as a result okay so what you were
saying before the finger length
that isn't the determinant of the dating
preference that is simply a
manifestation of testosterone levels
testosterone is
so you're saying shorter index finger
more testosterone it would appear more
testosterone also correlated with
shorter monogamous partnerships
normally it would be
either totally promiscuous mating
systems or mating systems in which males
compete with each other
for to monopolize groups of females so
what sometimes there's a harem-based um
social system where you have one male so
and a number of females in their
offspring
so species like gibbons which are
obligately monogamous very occasionally
they might have two maybe even three
females
exceptionally in their little group
uh but you know 98 of gibbon groups in
the wild are strictly monogamous and the
pair stays together for effectively for
life very long index fingers
no no they're very equal
right
and if you look at monogamous species
sorry polygamous species of primates
they then tend to have both both sexes
will have
index fingers which are
shorter than
uh the ring finger but
the more promiscuous sex
will have relatively shorter
um index finger uh compared to the
female so the males who tend to be the
more promiscuous sex or
even in
um
promiscuous species will have uh
uh a more deviant
um uh
finger ratio than the female as well and
you see that in humans as well
women's tens of thousands of people
right now looking at their hands yes i
know and working out
whether or not they're whether or not
their digits justify their desire to
cheat or to go out and have sex with
somebody tonight
yes well
well
you have to be a little bit careful
because the padding of the flesh and the
muscles around the finger bases
disguises the point where you should be
measuring from right so you you need to
find the joint between the
um finger
the bottom finger bone and the
top end of the first
hand bone if you like
um
and and and the differences are very
very small they would be hard to tell by
eye although i have seen some
males with spectacularly short
index fingers
which is just blindingly obvious and you
take one look at them in their behavior
and you go yes
you're an absolute bastard basically not
not just
not just in the world of of romance but
in the world of work you know just yeah
testosterone coursing through them yes
yes i mean just fizzing what's happening
people if you enjoyed that then press
here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]
you